It seems more like spiritual. Like he's doing some kind of like
he's doing like a palm reading for people who are racist, but
he's trapping them and like making them think non-racist thoughts.
It's very interesting. Okay. But I'm I'm suspecting that like
after a little bit here, we're going to drop into like straight
up racism near the end.
Okay, we've got
I now listen. This is a total wild card for content, but I do
know that these videos are supposed to be funny and I haven't
checked them out yet. Okay, so I've got two videos here, both
from
Prisa Insights.
They're physio reviews. All right,
they're physiotomy reviews.
Now, we're going to do this one first. Hello and welcome to another
select. >> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. We're going
to do this one first, which is Candace Owens, because then Oh,
no. Hold on. We're going to do Which one should we do first?
I was going to do Candace Owens first. Do we do Candace Owens
or Nick Fuentes first? I don't know. I don't know. But apparently
these are like somewhat funny videos. The Fuentes one kind of
popped off. I'm guessing that this guy's going to like Fuentes
based on his physiotomy. Okay. And he's got a Candace Owens one.
I'm just I'm saying I think
where did I hear about this channel? The where the place I heard
about this channel in the first place was
I think
uh a Fuentes clip on Twitter as in I think Fuentes was about
to watch the Candace Owens version of this. So let's watch Candace
Owens ones. That leads me to suspect that it will be very racist.
Okay. But then I we'll have to see how he how he works around
being not racist in the next one. We'll see. Hello everybody.
Welcome back to another celebrity face reading. My name is Taylor
and today we will be looking at none other
I I feel like this guy shares a couple not a lot but a little
commonality with Fuentes. The hairline looks quite similar. I'll
be real. Hairline looks very similar to me.
Possibly some eyebrow overlap. But
>> we'll uh we'll just have to see. We'll see where this
guy goes. I'm glad my physio reviews are on this guy's heads
though. Dennis Owens, the famous American conservative political
commentator turned conspiracy theorist who has been making waves
as of late with a lot of very bold theories and investigations,
especially regarding some of the most controversial topics out
there. Chief among them as of late, the unfortunate untimely
death of Charlie Kirk, which she claims she has some evidence
that there are some shadowy forces at work behind the scenes
at. In addition to this, she has also made waves by making some
pretty serious accusations about Reje Mccron, the wife of Emanuel
Macron, and her supposed true identity. Now, of course, with
bold accusations and allegations comes the need for the burden
of proof. And this is why I believe a lot of people have been
requesting that I analyze Candace Owens because they want to
find out if she's trustworthy or not. They want to know if she
is a reliable source for this sort of stuff. If she is a thorough
investigator or if she's the kind of person to sort of skip over
the details and go for the big picture thing and not really follow
up on her sources. Today I will be analyzing her face and physioamy
to try and figure out if Candace Owens is a trustworthy source
and what if any hidden agenda she may have. Before I get into
it, make sure you like, comment, subscribe, hit the bell so you
are notified next time I put out a face reading video. I'm looking
to start getting out multiple of these a week pretty soon. So
stay >> Damn, he's ramping up production. >> Stay
tuned. You're going to want to be subscribed for that. I've got
a lot >> I do wonder if this is going to be like the classic
just face symmetry if this guy's just going to be doing like
the the looks maxing stuff >> or if there's something else
going on.
>> If you want a face reading done for yourself or someone
you know, message me on my website, link is in the description.
And if you want to learn how to do face reading for yourself
and analyze people in your daily life, learn everything that
I know and more because you're going to be learning with me as
I get more information, make sure to check out my Patreon, which
is my physioamy academy. Link is in the description. And without
any further ado, let's get right into it. Now, before we get
into her personality and physiogamy, per se, we're going to take
a quick look at her phenotype, which is the physical expression
of her genetic heritage and ancestry. Now, obviously, Candace
is of African descent. She is African-American, descended from
West African slaves brought to the American South. And specifically,
I think that she has some sort of congalid phenotype. This means
that her ancestors probably
hold on. Does this guy have Does this guy have a video of him
playing ethnogesser? Cuz I feel like what would go hard for a
meme is like this guy staring thousand yards staring off like
Rainbolt. Okay. Playing um Geogesser. Not Geogesser. playing.
Oh, what the [__] is it called? Whatever the game
is. Is it Geogesser? What's the game? Right. This guy staring
off into the in the distance like he's playing like he's Rainbolt
playing Ethnogesser and just like slamming out guesses over and
over and over again. No, no, no, no. What's the one Rainbolt
plays? Hold on.
>> It is Geogesser. Okay. Yeah, hold on. Some of the most
videos of all time are me guessing where >> I want him
doing this. Okay. I want him doing this for no guesser.
>> Nice malt. >> Just a flash.
>> Flash and he guesses where that person's from. Okay,
that's this guy right now. Oh, whoops. This the Fentes video.
This one probably came from central Africa more so than West
Africa. From the Congo, maybe around Nigeria with one of those
ginid types. In any case, probably has some bantto ancestry in
there. And if you look at the shortness of nose combined with
otherwise somewhat Europeanesque features, maybe just a little
bit of pygmy, which I think is neat. Or in my own system of phenotypes
that I'm currently developing and will be putting out a book
for for too long. She would be what I call a gray Africanid,
which is one of the five unique African-American phenotypes found
in the New World. All right, with the phenotype out of the way,
we can now get into her personality and the analysis that you
guys are waiting for. We're >> Oh, side profile and temperament.
Going to start with her side profile, which will tell us about
her temperament and inborn characteristics. Now, it's a bit hard
to tell. There aren't that many good side profile pictures of
her, but my guess is that she is a sanguin. You can tell from
the protruding chin and the right angle on the jawline, that
90° angle there. This means that she by and large acts sort of
in the short term. She is rather impulsive, impatient, enthusiastic,
optimistic, rather charismatic. But she's not a pure sanguin.
The forehead does not slant back. She has a very high and rounded
forehead. That is a pure collaric forehead. So unlike a pure
sanguin, she's actually >> Okay, dude. He's got he's got
these things like trademarked like collar. He's he's literally
presopa insights. He's literally this guy is reinventing the
game. >> She's actually very willful and she can actually
think and plan in the long term. Now in practice, her energy
tends to be a bit more impatient, impulsive, and tends to kind
of get bored and exhausted with these long-term plans. But when
used properly, this combination can be very powerful because
it combines the very strong collar will with the very strong
sanguin energy of action. And we can see that this combination
has done her well throughout her career. She has managed to harness
both an incredibly stubborn, commanding, willful, long-term mind
and will and used it in congruence with a very enthusiastic and
charismatic energy of action and social energy from that sanguin
side. Now, with her temperament out of the way, we can now look
at her face shape, which will tell us about the broad chokes
of her personality and the archetype that she fulfills. Now,
from all the pictures that I've seen, I think that she has a
pretty pure Venus face shape. That's that heart or diamond shaped
face.
Got this carnival barker into esoteric science. I don't even
Is he even like this? I'll be real. Maybe he is racist. I don't
doubt that he's racist. Again, the place where I think I heard
about these videos from the first time was like a Fuentes clip
said he was going to watch the uh the Proopa Insights video on
Candace. Now, I don't know if that's because he did a video on
Nick as well that Nick could watch the video on on himself,
but it so I assume it's racist, but it actually hasn't been like
super negative yet, right? He's just gone, oh, like phenotypically
like this is the region probably. And then he's just saying different
traits that don't seem to be racial that much. He's like saying,
you know, upside down. It seems more like spiritual. Like he's
doing some kind of like
he's doing like a palm reading for people who are racist, but
he's trapping them and like making them think non-racist thoughts.
It's very interesting. Okay. But I'm I'm suspecting that like
after a little bit here, we're going to drop into like straight
up racism near the end. This is the face shape of the diplomat
archetype. This means that she is naturally romantic, interested
in loving and being loved, very interested in relationships in
general. And we see this in a lot of her videos. A lot of them
are about relationship drama and interpersonal stuff. Venusphace
people are also very interested in social causes. Whether it's
Ronald Reagan and his anti-communism, Emma Stone and her feminism,
or Leonardo DiCaprio and his environmentalism, Venuses are always
drawn towards helping other people. It's an extension of their
drive towards love. And Candace is no different. She also cares
a lot about social causes. No matter what her views at the time
are, she's very driven towards changing and reforming society
to better fit them. Whether she's a liberal or a conservative
or a national socialist, I don't know what she is now. She's
going to be very passionate and very driven with that. But she's
not passionate in a Martian warlike sort of way. She's very much
still a peacemaker and she wants to bring everyone to the table
and she just wants to ask questions. She just wants to get the
conversation going. Another
>> that is just like Candace >> Venus face person
is Joe Rogan. A lot of podcasters have this face because of course
Venuses are >> the just asking questions face. I'm seeing
it. >> The peacemakers and the talkers. Finally, on the
face shape, she has quite a large inner face which shows a lot
of sensitivity and reactivity. She can be easily overwhelmed
by stress and sometimes freak out and have to sort of retreat.
She's not very good at compartmentalizing or detaching from a
situation. She's always very involved. All right, with the broadstrokes
of her personality out of the way, her side profile and face
shape, we can now start to get into her facial features, which
will help fill in the minute details of her personality. Now,
usually for these, I will split them up by category or only look
at the most interesting features, but I think all of her features
are really interesting. So, we're just going to break them down
one at a time. We're going to start right at the top with her
eyebrows. Now, they're very long, which means that she's premeditated.
She likes to plan ahead. She likes to think in the long term.
She likes to come up with big plans for projects, investigations,
whatever it is she thinks and plans in the long term. These are
a very good compliment to that collaric forehead. But something
really interesting to notice is that they do have an asymmetrical
shape. Her left eyebrow is very curved, meaning that in her personal
uh-oh uh-oh
life, she is very consensusoriented,
empathetic, cares about the feelings of other people around her,
and makes decisions based on that. But her right eyebrow is more
arched. This means that she's more competitive, logical, controlling,
has a need to feel in charge, and is somewhat jealous. This is
a really interesting contrast with her now nemesis Nick Fuentes,
who I also analyzed, who, as I pointed out in my video on him,
has an arched left eyebrow and a curved right eyebrow. This is
because Nick Fuentes is the opposite of Candace Owens in this
regards. He projects as being very venian,
very consensusoriented.
He has an outer persona that is much more friendly and empathetic,
but inside he is by nature very harsh and competitive and assertive.
And I think that these opposite parallel almost mirror personalities
are just, >> you know, I never thought about it. I never
thought about it like that.
>> May have played a role in their initial drawing together
and then coming apart in their relationship, but that's all speculation.
Now, on to her most unique and prominent feature, her eyes. Right
off the bat, eyes are super wide set. This shows that she has
a wide view. She focuses on the big picture, not the details.
She's very tolerant, can be kind of spacey, and she's bad with
the details. And we see this with her stuff. She does not necessarily
follow the details and the evidence to where it naturally leads.
She comes up with a big picture view. She sees things and she
intuitits what is going on and then she tries to fill in the
details or has friends or followers do that for her. Now, this
can be an advantage. It can help her to see the forest for the
trees, see past stuff that other people are getting caught up
on and look at the whole picture, look at what's really going
on. But it can also be kind of a disadvantage in that she will
miss detail. She will get caught on red herrings perhaps. At
her best, she's visionary and at her worst, she's just plain
sloppy. This is further emphasized by the fact that she has very
round eyes. Now, they're not super big, so she's not super innocent
or naive. They're actually kind of small, so she's actually more
on the cynical side, but her worldview is
>> That's Come on, man. >> moral and emotional. Now,
I notice small round eyes a lot, ironically, on liberals when
people send me images of crazy liberals or LGBT activists or
whatever. I notice a lot of small round eyes. This is because
these people are very cynical. They think the world is against
them. They think the world is racist, corrupt, homophobic, whatever.
But it's not a logical critique. It's a moral emotional critique.
And we see this from Candace as well. She has a very moral emotional
worldview. Now, she doesn't necessarily say that society is set
up to be homophobic or racist, but rather that it's run by satanic
and Israel, which honestly probably correct, let's be honest.
But why is she so headstrong with asserting these views? Well,
that's because she has a positive canal tilt. That means that
she puts her own interest over those of others. She's very assertive,
rebellious, confident. She is always down to rock the boat rather
than keep the peace. Finally, with her eyes, she has very thin
upper eyelids, especially for someone of African descent. They
usually have thicker, fuller upper eyelids. This means that she
does not have a super strong need for intimacy or closeness.
She's very independent, something that is further emphasized
by her very, very widesped ears. These ears might be even more
widespread,
may even have trouble maintaining relationships in the long term.
But the really interesting thing here is that her ears are also
small. Now widesped ears of course indicate independence like
I said but small ears indicate that someone is easily influenced.
Now usually when someone has widesped ears their ears are also
large so they're independent and hard to influence. But you do
occasionally get people every now and then with widespreing
all these ideas. They're easy to influence but once they latch
on to an idea they're very headstrong with it and it's hard to
>> So here's the problem with this video actually. Does
he have a Wikipedia? Do do we have like a Proopa a Prooa insights
Wikipedia? Cuz I feel like
I feel like I need I feel like I'm playing a video game and I
don't know all the categories and I need like the game facts
page or like the uh you know what I mean? I need I need like
what all of the traits mean. And I need like a rubric somewhere
that I can look through and I could like reapply to people cuz
right now he's telling me all these things but I don't know like
I don't have it all laid out in the same place >> out of
it or get them to doubt it. It's a curious paradox and I think
we see it in Candace in Spades. We know that the Bruge Mcronone
being a man thing is not her idea. It came from some French author
that she picked up and now she ran with it in her own very independent
way. Now her nose of course being of African descent. It's short
but it's short even for a person of African descent. Usually
her gray cell African phenotype, they usually have somewhat longer
noses, but her nose is itty bitty short. This means that she's
very actionoriented. She's not much of a contemplative, patient,
thoughtful person. She wants to get out and do stuff. Now again,
just like with the whites eyes, this can be a strength, but it
can also be a weak.
Hold on. No, no, no. I'm not just looking for a phronology book,
Maximus. I'm looking for this guy's rubric. Okay.
I don't see any of the pieces. And this guy's like not It's not
the same thing. He's got like names for his classes and stuff.
This is I don't think this is the
>> I want I want the rubric. Okay. I want the thing that
he uses to repeat this >> Weakness
be very enthusiastic and very energetic. She wants to get out
there and get the podcast out, get the word out there. But on
the other hand, she might jump the gun on things and she might
be a little overly impulsive sometimes. However, when you look
at it from the side, her nose is actually rather straight and
has a level tip. This means that she is rational, reliable, and
has a cool-headed disposition. Now, only note on the filtrum,
which is that little ridge that runs between the nose and the
upper lip. Hers is very narrow, which means that she has a very
strong moral impulse, and she puts principles above pleasure.
Now, last, but certainly not least, for a communicator like Candace,
we are going to look at her mouth. She has a very small mouth,
actually, not the smallest I've ever seen, but pretty small relative
to her face as a whole and her facial features. This means that
she's actually naturally a quiet, reserved person who is resistant
to new social connections. She's actually naturally kind of an
introvert, I would think, but she has a very good public persona
and she cares about the world and about people and about interacting
and getting her voice out there. So, she does it for work, but
I think if you found her at a party, she'd sort of be off on
her own or with her friends. She really only speaks when she
feels the need to. Not too much of a blabbermouth, I think. But
speaking of her communication style, her upper lip can tell us
a lot about that. And she has the high and narrow arch upper
lip shape. That is the moon upper lip. That means that her communication
style is imaginative, blurry, dreamy, somewhat imprecise. Again,
we get back to sloppiness, blurriness, imprecision. Yeah, she
has big vision, big dreams, and all that, but she is bad when
it comes to the details, and this further emphasizes it. So,
in conclusion, overall picture, imprecise, a bit sloppy at her
worst, but visionary at her best, great at seeing the big picture,
bad with the details, and most importantly, extremely independent,
driven, rebellious. Honestly, the biggest surprise to me about
her crash out with Daily Wire, is the fact that it didn't happen
any sooner. With ears like that, with a canal tilt like that,
with a nose like that, I'm personally shocked she was able to
maintain that working relationship for that long. She is an independent,
driven woman, and she cannot be held down. She is 100% a strong
independent black woman who don't need no Israeli money. And
with all that being said, [laughter]
>> that concludes my physioamy analysis of Candace Owens.
I hope you enjoyed the video. This has been Taylor from For Insights
reminding you to always judge a book by its cover. Thank you
for watching.
[laughter]
>> That's an awesome Dude, that's an awesome tagline though
for his thing, right? Always judge a book by its cover. It's
all right there. I I'll be honest.
Did I pick I don't think I picked up like actual racism there.
I might have missed it. I'm Trust me, I'm a little slum. I'm
like I could easily miss it. I didn't pick up like actual It
seemed like he had like positive traits, possible negatives,
and they didn't seem to be like racially driven that I could
It's like he took something that you're expecting to be super
racist and that wasn't that racist. Uh that reminds me think
of the allegations made against Destiny. I just I like I would
need to see evidence, right? Like Norm doesn't like Destiny.
Um I don't know. I don't even know what Norm was alleging there
to be honest with you. What was it? Groomed and something groomed
and paid by Israel.
I don't know. I'd have to see some evidence. It's just who knows
what the [__] Norm is saying.
Like not that I believe Destiny has morals. I just don't know.
Apparently he hasn't denied anything. I mean has he streamed?
Is he aware of it?
What allegations? I think Norm Finkelestein seemed to suggest
that Destiny took money from Israel to shill for them.
Like it's not that I don't believe it could happen. I just don't
I don't see
like it's way more it explains it way more that like he got in
fights with people and he was like, "Oh, Israel did nothing wrong."
And then people started freaking out at him and then he just
kept doubling down over and over again.
Like that that seems more likely,
right?
He just like dosed kid his kid his kid did kidid his way to like
being the strongest Israel defender.
Oh, that's really Don't don't say that. That's That's crazy.
That's That seems way more way more understandable or way more
believable to me.
But it's not it's not that I don't believe it. I need to see
like literally some kind of evidence for it. Hello and welcome
to another celebrity face reading. My name is Taylor and today
we'll be looking at none other than the infamous Nicholas J.
Fuentes. Now I'm not like I will say though somehow Briana Woo
definitely started getting paid by Israel, right? And there was
like political overlap there. There's political overlap with
Brianna Woo and then Brianna Woo and Arerodite and it's like
so I like there's something going on there that I feel like you
could get there eventually, but I there's just nothing overt.
So it just seems odd. not a Grober or anything, but I've been
keeping tabs on this guy for a while. He's a very fascinating
figure, especially in terms of his political longevity. He has
become kind of a
household name, kind of the face of the radical
nationalistic white nationalist anti. I wonder if this guy will
talk about how like much just how much
Nick Fuentes benefited from getting a little bit fat like that
when he was as skinny as he was when he was like in high school
like right at the sorry in his first year of college he looked
like such a nerd right and he he put on like I don't know 10
lbs and that did like the world for him I wonder if this guy
will we'll touch on that >> medicic right online and somewhat
in person as well he >> did you see the did you see the
Jared Holt interview will or interview Will Stansel about his
show.
No. Was it funny? Sort of the go-to guy to bring on podcasts
if you want the most controversial out there farright kind of
take on race Israel influence and so kind of spicy. Definitely
the most controversial figure that I've covered. But I've got
no worries about it. I'm not here to talk about politics. I'm
here to analyze his face and let you know what it tells us about
his
>> I just want the ethnogesser on Nick Fuentes. Okay,
I just want to see where where are we putting him? Where where
is he going? >> So, without any further ado, let's get
right into it. And we're going to start off with his phenotype,
which is more or less his biological race. How his genes and
heritage express themselves in his physical appearance. Now,
I know that he is obviously part Hispanic from the last name
and from other things that I've heard, but I really don't see
it in the appearance. Okay, this guy's already capping. I don't
see much Native American and I don't even see that much Spanish.
What he looks like to me is very Irish. Specifically, he exists
>> Oh, never mind. Never mind. Shots fired. >> A
really strong example of the Brun phenotype. Brun is a chromagnet
phenotype. It's very common along the Atlantic coast of Europe.
>> You can tell Fuentes he's not Italian. Uh-oh. in northern
and western Europe, especially in more isolated mountainous village
areas. Brun is one of the very typical Irish types, and you see
that with him. Strong brow, ridge, deep set eyes, short almost
snub nose, and that kind of thick wavy mop of brown hair on the
top of the head with those green eyes. It looks very brun to
me. He's partially albanized as well, which leads to some extra
shortness of the nose, some increased softness, decreased robustness
to the features, gives him that sort of look. All right, with
that out of the way, we're going to get into his physioamy, his
personality
There are white redheaded Mexicans. Okay,
Ashers, that's not what he's talking about. He's talking about
like where did this uh where did this phenotype originate, right?
He's saying like where did these genetic features most become
most pronounced? >> We're going to start side profile,
which will tell us a little bit about his >> Oh, damn.
He's going to use the mug shot >> traits. As you can see
here, if you've been following me for a bit, you might say, "Oh,
he's a sanguin. A pure sanguin." But I would caution against
that. He's tilting his head up quite a bit. He's posing for the
mug shot. If we edit it and tilt it down a bit, we see his actual
side profile, which is mostly sanguin, but not entirely. You
see, he's actually a sanguin collaric mix. He has a sanguin forehead
and a sanguin chin, but a collar. >> Let's be real, okay?
Again,
not doesn't hit the gym. Proudly doesn't exercise.
Few too many scoops of ice cream. He's He's holding his chin
up cuz he doesn't want to get the double chin for the mug shot.
Right. That's That's really what's going on there. Very very
smart of this guy to not be fooled. Okay.
Holding the chin up to not get the double chin going. Sir, he's
holding his his actual chin up to not get that double chin going.
All right.
very intelligent, very profile, which is mostly sanguin, but
not entirely. You see, he's actually a sanguin collaric mix.
He has a sanguin forehead and a sanguin chin, but a collaric
jawline. This is actually the opposite of my temperament, which
is a collar forehead and chin with a sanguin jawline. So, what
does this mean about his
Why is this guy got mo Nick like that? What the
>> just just going to mo him casually like that? That's
messed up, man. >> Forehead and >> Nick. Nick Nick's
in better shape now. Get a new side profile picture with a sanguin
jawline. So, what does this mean about his personality? Well,
the sanguin type is very outgoing, optimistic, friendly, courageous,
kind of kingly and regal, somewhat self-centered in that way
where they want to be the center of attention. They want to be
in charge, but it's not in a micromanaging or controlling way.
It's very much in a heroic lionlike sort of way. Sanguins make
great athletes, actors, salesmen, military officers, soldiers,
or in this case, live streamers. They are well suited for live
streaming, especially stuff like live debate. However, the collar
jawline means that unlike a typical sanguin, which is more of
a short-term runner, they kind of lose interest and energy pretty
quickly in long-term endeavors. He actually has the long-term
energy of action of the collar type, which is defined by its
long-term endurance and intense energy. So, this means that he's
going to be more was this was it is this the inverse of Candace
now here as well? are him and Candace like actual
Hold on. Where do I got Where do we have our Here we go. Right
here.
>> Unlike a pure sanguin, she's actually very willful and
she can actually think and plan slant back. She has a very high
and rounded forehead. That is a pure
>> So collaric forehead, sanguin chin, and Nick is
uh the collar the collar chin, sanguin forehead. Ah, they're
exact opposites in side profile and like face shape, too.
>> Sanguin and optimistic, impulsive, impatient in his
intellect and immediate action, but in the long term, he's going
to be a lot more stable, a lot more focused, a lot more locked
in in terms of his work and his projects. Now, that all sounds
very positive, and it is, but the downside comes in social situations.
He's going to be very charismatic and outgoing and friendly and
optimistic and generous and very sanguin and his personal interactions
when first meeting people. But as they get to know him and as
they >> Bro, what the is this Chudlo Logic thumbnail? Excuse
me. Hold on. Let me pull this up real quick. Let me pull this
up so I can get a better picture of it. One second. One second.
What is this thumbnail? What is this thumbnail? What is this
thumbnail?
What is this? What is this? What is this? What is this? This
is
This is some pretty
uh [laughter] Okay. Okay.
That's a little out there. That's a
Jesus Christ. >> More routine, more serious, more long-term.
He's going to become a lot more austere, cold, serious, and collaric.
All right, with that out of the way, we're going to now look
at his face shape, which will tell us about his personality archetype
and the broad strokes of his personality in general. As you can
see here, in his youth, he had a very strong Venus face shape.
That's that diamond face shape. That means that he had the diplomat
personality archetype. He was very friendly, very focused on
loving and being loved, on social causes and aesthetics, and
on making peace. He wanted to bring warning parties to the negotiating
table to get them to agree.
it wasn't a pure Venus. There was also a square earth element
there which would express itself in some extra practicality,
groundedness, spunkiness, a sort of lively practical kind of
intelligence and I think in his traditionalism. I can remember
actually back in the internet blood sports days if you can remember
that absolute dumpster fire. He was known as the optics guy.
He was the guy who would come out and say, "Hey guys, maybe we
shouldn't be walking around flying swastika flags and yelling
siege or whatever. Maybe we should try to >> Clever clever
misdirect saying mispronouncing it. Saying siege."
Clever. I see. I see what you're doing. >> Present ourselves
nice. Maybe we should look good. Maybe we should present ourselves
well. Maybe we should be friendly and understanding and practical
with [laughter] our
guy looks like he's a silent film villain. [laughter] Yes, he
does. >> Which I think you can see is very much a Venus
Earth combination. That [laughter] combination of good aesthetics,
peacemaking,
putting your argument out there in understandable terms and earthy
sort of pragmatism. And [clears throat] now in the present day,
he still very much has that square earth element there. So he's
still very pragmatic, practical in his intelligence quite grounded.
But that Venus element has gone out the window in exchange for
its opposite, a Mars face shape. That's that rectangular face
shape. This is the warrior archetype. This means that nowadays
he is far more impatient, impulsive,
very intense feeler. He loves and hates with equal intensity.
Other examples of Mars face shapes would be people like Donald
Trump or Elon Musk. And you can see how the tempers run hot with
those personalities. They have a strong impulse to fight and
this can be a very good thing. This can drive them to fight for
a political agenda, for example. But it can also hurt relationships.
As the old saying goes, Nick Fuentes has been kicked out of 109
friendships. And that is a Mars phase shaped thing that probably
didn't used to happen to him, but he is so hot blooded now. He's
so dedicated to his cause that the tempers flare up and he's
out of the relationship. That bridge is burned. Dude, but again,
that's a Mars phase thing.
The bad with the good. It happened with Donald Trump and Elon
Musk. Or you look at a non-political example of two Mars face
shapes in a relationship. Look at Bradelina. Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie, both pure Mars face shapes, and the relationship ran hot
but extinguished quickly. So, it makes sense to me that someone
like Nick Fuentes with a Mars face shape, that aggressive warrior
archetype, and someone like Keith Woods, who has a pretty pure
Mercury face shape, that's that triangular face shape, which
is very sensitive, attentionseeking, intellectual. You get that
warrior archetype combined with that magician archetype.
They're going to be a powerful combination for a while, but eventually
they're going to start to clash temper. >> They're literally
building a fantasy party over there in the white nationalist
movement. This is crazy. You're going to flare. The Mars face
person is going to be too aggressive. >> This is You're
trolling, right? This is astrology.
Okay. Yeah. Just have fun, dude. Just have just let go. Have
fun for a second. >> The Mercury face person is going to
be too sensitive and they're going to split ways. And we saw
that's what happened. The last thing I'll say on his face is
that he has quite a small inner face, which means that he is
quite stress resistant, aloof, and maybe a bit detached as well.
All right. Now, we're going to look at his facial features, which
will help fill in the minute details of his personality. We're
going to start from the top with his eyebrows. They are quite
thick naturally, as you can see, but it looks like they are thinning
somewhat. This means that while he naturally has a lot of energy
and stamina, and it's quite intense. It has been wearing thin
recently, and he's been losing energy. It's not that severe,
but it's present for sure. His eyebrows are long, which means
that he is a pretty patient person who likes to plan things out.
He's very premeditated in his action and likes to draw these
big longear
plans for his political and personal
>> They are quite low set, however, which means that he's
pretty quick and decisive when it comes to judgments. He doesn't
take a long time to ascertain all the facts and get everything
together before he comes to an emotional judgment of someone
or something. He makes those judgments pretty quickly. They're
snap judgments. And the last thing I'll mention is that there's
a very strong asymmetry with his eyebrows. His left eyebrow in
his youth was pretty straight, but now it's pretty sharply arched.
This means that his decision-making process in his private life
and in personal affairs. >> Okay, I
I've done I've gone as far as I can. All right, this is this
is funny. I I can't do two of these back toback. This is too
much too much back to back. Okay, just a little too much back
to back. Oh, boy. Okay. All right.
What else do we got here? Because otherwise if if there's nothing
else if there's anything interesting or pressing I I'll pull
up you know links if people wait go to conclusion. Okay fine
hold on we watch conclusion real quick. That was [snorts] Candace
>> Hello and
we'll watch conclusion real >> All right. So that concludes
my physioamy analysis on Nicholas J. Fuentes. Let me know what
you think. >> Hold on. I want to I want to watch the asymmetry
bit. >> All right. Last thing we're going to do is break
down his facial asymmetry. I alluded to this before with talking
about his inner and outer persona and how he kind of hides his
power level. This is a composite image of two left sides of his
face. [laughter] >> Hold on. >> Looks very confident,
very driven. >> Why does this look so funny? Why is this
so funny to me?
>> Very kind of aggressive and masculine. This is his inner
self. This is his true self. This is who he really is deep down.
And it shows in his personal life and in private. But then compare
and contrast that to the right side of his face. This is like
I said his outer persona. What does persona mean? Persona is
the Latin word for mask. It is the dude. What the This is not
his mask. This is not who he pretends to be. Dude, it's got to
be the opposite, right? This guy up his signs. This has to be
the like fighting one and then this has to be the sensitive one,
right?
What the what? What? what >> persona. What does persona
mean? Persona is the Latin word for mask. It is the mask that
he puts on to present himself to the world. So we can say that
deep down he is a much more aggressive driven warrior type very
dedicated to his
>> This is the aggressive driven warrior type and this
is the like sensitive
>> whether that is Catholicism, white nationalism, America
first, populism,
whatever that may be. but he has this outer persona that presents
it in this very friendly Venian peacemaking sort of way where
he'll go on the podcast and he'll put on the hoodie and he'll
say, "Hey, I'm just a regular old American like you, but I just
have some concerns about Israel." Not saying there's necessarily
anything insidious with that. Most effective political actors
do something like that. You're very locked in in private, but
then in public, you present yourself as a much more moderate
and common sense uh friendlier kind of guy. All right, so that
concludes my physioamy analysis on Nicholas J. Fuentes. Let me
know what you think in the comments below. And make sure you
leave a comment letting me know which celebrity I should do a
physioamy analysis of next. This video was done in response to
a comment by never again 125 under my last video. Thank you for
requesting that. Thank you for leaving that comment. And the
top comment under this video will be the next celebrity reading
I do. This has been Taylor from Persona Insights reminding you
to always judge a book by its cover. Thank you for
>> Wow. Wow. Oh my god. Is that really what Sam Hyde used
to look like? What the?
That's an old picture of Sam Hyde.
What the hell? What the going on here? Jesus Christ.
Okay. Crazy.
All right.
Let's You never seen that? I've never seen that. No, I've I've
literally never seen that. Okay. All